The Humble s23 Fe or Fan Edition will be
running through our gaming Gauntlet of
hongkai styl genin impact Call of Duty
mobile with the backbone and pubg mobile
performance- wise the Samsung s23 Fe is
running a Snapdragon 8 gen 1 for its
processor and an adrenal 734 GPU 8 gigs
of RAM 256 gigs of storage and
everything plays out on a 6.4 in Dynamic
amola 2x hdr10 plus 120 HZ screen and it
has a 4,500 million battery so before we
run the test let's do a baseline
temperature check with our temperature
gun real quick let's check the back and
we are running a very low 26 at the top
here and at the bottom we are going down
to 27 slightly hotter here and let's
check the front
27.6
27.7 and all right not too bad I mean
this what we're starting off with so
with that let's get into our first game
honai starl all right now that we're in
h star let's check some things real
quick okay so we're running very high
for everything at 60 FPS as well so with
that let's just check out our characters
real quick and see how this performs and
so far we are seeing a little bit of
frame stuttering just a little bit let's
see how this performs when we switch
between
characters okay not too bad can now way
zoomed in let swipe
around
and yeah yeah so far so good with that
let's enter the simulated universe so
far it looks like we are dropping frames
a little bit here just look at that so
far so good I
think but we do see a bit of f shopping
in
there we're just having fun try this on
for
side o okay
yeah we have quite a bit of let it quick
rame drops not major ones but the small
enough to
notice
go all right let's just hit
[Music]
them I me honestly like the game looks
really good on this screen it's it's
really just this thing obvious this PHA
obviously was not made for like very
high
settings
oh
boy all right let's go
with check out this awesome
move all
right my turn watch this all right let's
slow this down and let's use jaar's Al
and see how well performs with it of cuz
honestly it's one of the more graphic
intensive
alties
oo yeah as you can see that's
happening nice
let's ice never F okay this is doing a
lot better than one just now for some
reason rules are to be
broken
nice there one
down second guy
down try that again nice and that's done
all right so with that oh okay so the
back is getting a little done it without
me but not it's not as hot as you think
it would be but let's check temperatures
real
quick and right we're running at
41 40ish de at the front over here it
gets less warm as we go down but it's
still pretty warm I didn't realize it's
41 that's a best part let's check the
back 35 at the bottom not Doo bad well
here go higher that's where the process
is at 37 39 36.5
40 okay that's actually not too bad
obviously the front will be a lot warmer
because of the screen but we're doing
pretty fine at the back okay surprising
okay before get the next game we stopped
up 100% and currently we are at 90% so
that the 10% of our time for about 20
minutes of game play so with that let's
get into our next game gin impact before
we get to get impact let's check
temperatures real quick we're 90 we're
90% and let's check the
front 34 all right things have gone up
pretty good 35.6 all right it's all
right
and then let's check the
back 35.6 35 35.8 and yeah we're doing
we're doing pretty good this thing has
actually gone down quite a bit I'm I'm
quite impressed with how well this thing
handles heat all right now that we're in
zuma City let's check out set things
real quick graphics and we're set
everything on high yeah that's pretty
much the highest we can go 60 FPS and
yeah that's that's how things right now
and let's just check how the game is
like so far I mean the game again looks
really good on this display that Samsung
has going on and our characters look
really good as well but let's see how
well this performs when we switch
characters real
quick all
right not too bad and with that so far I
haven't seen any like minor major frame
St doing so I think we are in for a
pretty good run I hope so with that
let's run through the C with I look of
course right and so far yeah okay yeah
it is straining a little bit but also I
kind of realized it's a bit dark right
now so let's just up that a little
bit all let's keep
moving and as you can see FPS is
dropping by a little bit little by
little it's kind of increasing here and
there oh boy but
it's pretty manageable it just comes in
very very short bur but other than that
I think it's
fine all right nothing too bad to ride
home about but oh boy okay it's bad okay
we just going to see how this fast like
in
combat all right even as we are jumping
up and hitting that SW on the ground you
can see the drops there even oh look at
the D it gets see that oh boy okay let's
get into some combat and
exploration
right as you look out I mean it's just a
lot of mountains but it's looking really
good raining distance is pretty far in
this thing so so far no huge drops
thankfully that en SP very nicely just
letting the
stamina recharge before I go up again
let's go oh it below us right
now okay here we
go BL where oh over there okay you got
this there we go and a one and a two and
a one
two three I
believe pay your all right here we go h
everybody stand
back oh it's a fire dude as
well all right let's get
this all
right where you at oh there you
are all right and that's done can't run
from you we
go so
good all right let's go with that Alti
real quick time for
Retribution not too
bad okay little bit of
frame drops here and there but other
than that I think it's
fine that's a last guy
here we
are go let
[Music]
dude nice all right that's done so with
that um exploration and also combat
outside doesn't seem to be doing too bad
but now let's see how things are like in
the spiral Abyss all right line them up
and and then just wackies and honestly
in part bit so far looking pretty
good got get rid of this a real
quick come on get to him all right one
more time with
the here you go
oh hold that down and one more
that should setle some stuff all right
so in the spiral abys everything is
playing out just nice no yeah so in the
spiral B everything's playing out fine
no frame rate drops no no so in the
no major or minor fre drops or anything
I'm actually having a really good time
let's just continue for a bit more for
this one just get of all these
dudes take them all
down still no huge R jobs
whatsoever we're doing pretty good in
time all right
nice let's light it
up oh gosh Stager
guy of light all right let's check
temperatures real quick the front we are
at 4 de I don't see anything hitting
above or at least you know hitting 41°
so we're doing pretty good over
here and 36.5 for the bottom let's check
the back top to bottom again I'm for
life balance 36.7 37.2
40 at the back nothing hitting 41 and of
course it gets lower as we go to the
bottom this phone has been a pretty
solid phone so far for its specs and for
its price point and I'm pretty surprised
at how well it manages the so with that
let's get into our next game Call of
Duty mobile with the backbone of course
and for that we are currently 83%
battery we started off at 90 after hon
stario so before we get into Call of
Duty mobile this channel supported by
Brands who help us improve our content
and keep us going so stick around for
this sponsored message here at geek
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but secret La gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back to the arms and even
something for your butt this mix of
Forman function helps the Titan Evo 2022
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co so now we're going to be
playing Call of Duty mobile with the
backbone but before that let's check
temperates real quick so starting from
the top 20.9 everything is going up
pretty nicely we're currently 81%
battery
and yep pretty much uniform and
everything is cool across the
board
yep all right check the
back 27.4 28.8
29 okay we're doing pretty good all
right 30 on here just now but let's
attach the backbone and get into Call of
Duty all right so let's go to setting
real quick and Graphics so go go on Max
and let's see I can't go any more than
that graphic quality on high and better
Ro we going to turn on anti-alien soon
and that should keep us and put us in a
very good spot also it's a bit bright
let Just Adjust that real
quick just Aion more all right we'll see
how that works out in game and with that
let's start a Shad preload obviously the
speakers are doing too good right now
because it's being covered by the
backbone so you know use Bluetooth ear
pieces earbuds whatever or you can jack
in straight into here this 2.5 need Jack
at the bottom left controller here and
if you want to charge things up you can
charge your phone through this USBC port
on the right side and with that let's
get into this
match there we
go going to go straight
down hit hard hit fast
all
right
in you see there's a key unit coming but
oh gu you
know where is that
from see how this looks like in first
person honestly I'm having a really good
time playing with this thing it's it's
very smooth when it comes to Call of
Duty mobile a bit of frame Stu do here
in there but honestly it's quite
manageable okay the frame something most
see happens when you transition from
third to first person but you know it's
okay oh you can kill someone let's do
that oh there you
go
nice
all right that's two
kills that's one
[Applause]
down oh Bo that was
bad
don't okay last guy on the other
side oh found
him all right close one but you got
him I can't see anyone oh
okay
nice come on come
on okay let's uh let's cross
I wonder where he was fighting at
last all right my left hand is numb
right now cuz I'm been resting on the
table but yes very tense moments
happening oh Jesse right on top
there
move
back and you're
down all
right nice about 20ish minutes and we
are currently at 73% which isn't too bad
actually and we are in the final moments
of the game there are two more people I
need to kill and I have no idea where
they are so that's great the safe zone
is collapsing it's kind of safe on this
side and of course I'm moving in
together with this with the barrier with
the circle I mean all right final moment
of the game we got the guy got the guys
right there there we go and okay and we
won okay so uh camera went camera
overheated but at least we won the game
so with that let's remove the phone out
of the backbone and check out temper
just real quick we are at
72%
36.6
35.9
34.8 all right not too bad it's not even
we are barely at genino hanai
temperatures here at the back from the
bottom to the
top 35
32.6
and yeah we're doing pretty good nice
okay pretty good temperature still don't
what to do are still doing pretty good
and with that let's move on to our final
game pubg mobile now before we get into
our last game pubg mobile let's check
temperates real quick we currently at
72% and let's check temperatures
currently the top is a 26ish
26 all right pretty uniform across the
rest of the phone the front here let's
check the back
26.7 27 and we're doing a okay all right
so with that let's move on to our next
game pubg mobile all right now they the
main page let's check our settings real
quick and our settings are where the
hell are the set
thingss oh over here right set things
Graphics all right smooth Graphics as
always and extreme frame rate as you
guys like it and everything else is set
properly anding four times let's set it
in all right everything's been applied
so let's just get get into a match all
is smooth and I can't believe even
though I said to randomize we are still
playing on a Wrangle C130 is looking
pretty good and so far everything's
pretty smooth I mean again we playing
this on smooth and extreme frame rate so
I think we're good oh yellow has other
plans whatever let's just wait for
school and one
twoie do
going to be gliding so far so good it's
again I I I don't think I mentioned but
the f is actually a pretty good size for
gaming even for my hands which are
usually which are pretty
huge one thing I do have to note is that
yeah we are moving in pretty quick and
now we're going to
dip I believe we should be able to hit
the
school yep there we go okay open up the
shoot and we're going to be hitting
in right about there that a gymnasium
okay
sick Uzi off the bat oh we got a
vector can use that oh I got no I have
no sides wow oh hello where is
blue and Blue's dead where did blue
die oh okay see you
know okay he's
down but I believe there more people
around
us okay we got a level two
helmet and blue is just dead right now I
think it's disconnected as well oh he's
still alive
oh someone
shooting okay I got some time before
they
reload all right let's keep
moving nice thank you green these guys
are up here it's right
above oh
nice okay the GU
[Applause]
down
okay pretty tense first half it's a good
[Applause]
thing oh damn it okay I'm down that's a
first it's been a while actually got
downed kill
me all right for
ideas it's okay it's
fine we're coming in right
now all right we are slowly but surely
hitting bitching
Q
all right almost there I believe we can
make it yeah we can we can make it we're
doing okay we are doing just
fine in our
dip all
right just hit hard go hard for those
houses on the left side of
town
go ah weapons weapons weapons weapons
weapons no weapons great oh okay we got
we pistols that's fun all
right oh my gosh okay it's okay we're
going to get the three before moreart
hits
uh where is three
he got kill right here
oh help damn it he was in the grass
let's
go that's great don't give up
okay okay no he still can get me yeah
get him get him fire
fire why you fool okay never mind I'm
not going to question
it just single shot my guy like there
you go
awesome I guess that's as far as I'm
going to go with pubg mobile but you
know you guys can see that it pretty
well it no minor or major frame rate
drops or frame stop doing whatsoever
it's doing pretty good so with that
let's just check temperatures real
quick all right honestly very modest
numbers here temperature wise and okay
let's check the
back 32 all right still pretty good
numbers they've honestly moved up by
like maybe five or six more degrees
enemies ahead so we're doing pretty good
here as well and ahead with that I think
we can call quit on this match and get
into our final thoughts the Samsung s23
Fe is a treat for fans of the brand or
just anyone looking for an affordable
phone without compromising performance
of course we're running the highest
settings possible on hongkai and genshin
but the s23 Fe performed a lot better
than I expected especially with its
Snapdragon 88 gen 1 processor with
pretty promising thermal management when
the games get intense pubg and C mobile
play Super well on this and I need to
mention that the size of this is a
perfect fit for most hands and it feels
good to play Bare Bones and by that I
mean without a cover would you be
getting the Samsung S3 Fe let me know in
the comment section below leave your
questions there too if you do have any
we'll do our best to get to them if you
like what we do make sure to follow us
on all of our socials right here and
maybe leave a like And subscribe to us
it goes a long way if you want to see
more stuff check this
[Music]
out